This time as we do the simplification, we'll need to pull out a factor of omega R to see that indeed we have an eogenvector
and that vector of omega R represents the eigenvalue associated with this eigenvector.
So that's a second eigenvector
eigenvalue pair of NA.
We can identify additional eigenvectors using exactly the same reasoning, And in fact, if we simply replace omega R
with omega R to the power J for each J between zero and R minus one, we'll always get an eigenvector,
and the associated eigenvalue will be omega R to the power J.
So this actually includes
psi zero and pis one, which we already saw
as well as R minus two, other eigenvector, eigenvalue pairs.
They all work in basically the same way, and to verify them, we just need to know that A to the power R equals one
as well as omega R to
the power R equals one.
There are other eigenvectors of MA like cat zero for instance, but they aren't going to be useful to us and we don't need to worry about them.
We only need to worry about psi zero through psi R minus one.
Let's focus on psi one for a moment, just to try to understand why it is that we care about these eigenvectors
and what they can tell
us about the order R, which is what we're trying to find.
Supposing that we're given
the eigenvector psi one, we can attempt to learn
R in the following way.
First, we perform phase
estimation on this eigenvector using a quantum circuit that
implements the operation MA.
What we get is an approximation to theta, which is one over R in this case.
And second because we're looking for R and we have an
approximation to one over R, the natural thing to do is
to compute the reciprocal
and to round it off to
the nearest integer. We have to round like this
because R has to be an integer.
But we don't have one of our R exactly, we just have an approximation to it.
But if the approximation is good enough, we'll get R when we round,
which is what we're looking for.
And now the question is how much precision do we need to correctly determine R by computing the reciprocal and rounding?
Or in other words, how accurate does our
approximation need to be to make this all work?
Well, it turns out that we do need a pretty accurate approximation.
For example, we can't
afford to confuse one over R with one over R plus one, or one over R minus one for instance.
In those two fractions, one over R plus one and
one over R minus one are pretty close to one
over R when R is large.
But although we do need a
pretty accurate approximation, we don't need a ridiculously
accurate approximation, and it can be shown that
if our approximation
satisfies the inequality that
we have here on the screen, then rounding off will
give us the right answer.
I won't try to argue that in this video, but it is shown in the written
material for the lesson in case you're interested in the details.
And if that's the accuracy
that we're going for, then it suffices to use a
number of control qubits in the phase estimation procedure
that's equal to two times
the length of N plus one.
Where as we had in the previous lessons, the length of N is the number of bits that we need to express N in binary.
By the way, if we're content
to get the best approximation with probability at least 40% and we don't try to
increase our confidence
like I described earlier, then we don't actually need the plus one.
But in any case, we have that the number
of control qubits we need is linear in the length of N
written as a binary string.
We've seen that if we have
the eigenvector psi one, we can use phase estimation to find R, provided we use enough accuracy.
Unfortunately it's not so easy to get our hands on this eigenvector.
So let's ask a different question.
Suppose we don't have psi one, but rather we have psi
for a random choice of J.
Can we still figure out what R is? Or at the very least can we
figure out something about R?
And the answer is yes, we can figure out something
about R, at least on average.
What we can do is to try
to figure out J over R using a very similar method
to the one that we just saw,
but with a key difference.
First, we'll do exactly the
same thing we did before, which is to run the phase
estimation procedure on the eigenvector psi J.
And what we'll get is an
approximation to J over R, as opposed to one over R,
which is what we had before.
But now we have a small problem, because computing the
reciprocal won't give us R, it will give us R over J.
And by the way, we're not
assuming that we know what J is, we're simply given psi J for a random J,
and we're not told what J is. So what can we do?
Well, it turns out that there's a well-known
classical algorithm that can help us, called the
continued fraction algorithm.
And what this algorithm can do is to take our approximation
Y over two to the M and tell us which fraction U over V,
written in lowest terms, and where U and V are both
integers smaller than N is closest to our approximation.